-Welcome back.
-Thank you.
-I want to get into
all the new things.
But first,
I want to talk about --
I know you just finished
filming "Ant-Man," okay?
-Mm-hmm.
-"Ant-Man and the Wasp."
-It's "Quantumania."
-"Quantumania."
-Uh-huh.
-It's just one name.
-One name. "Quantumania."
-Just "Quantumania."
-"Quantumania."
-Yeah.
These Marvel movies,
I mean, also, like --
-Crazy quantum...
-It's so many quantums
that it's Quantumania.
-Yes.
-That's how many --
That's why they --
There's too many quantums
to talk about.
Now, when you signed up for
the first quantum...
Kind of, right?
-Okay, I'll go with that.
-Thank you. You'll go with that.
You do the first "Ant-Man,"
and you go, "Oh, this is cool."
And you're in that film.
Does Marvel tell you that you're
going to be another --
You're gonna leap...
Does Marvel explain
to you that --
how many quantums
you're in, possibly?
Is there any -- No.
-No. No.
They're very mysterious.
-Yes.
-And, you know,
they're very secretive,
of course, of their story lines
and all of that.
-They're so secretive.
-So secretive.
-But I kind of like that.
Well, it must be hard for you.
-It's a little hard, because,
you know, I met with Peyton,
and I knew a little bit
about the character,
but there was no script.
And they -- And you have to
commit without actually
having read anything.
-Have you ever done that before?
-No.
-Wow! That's -- You have
a lot of faith there.
-I did.
But, you know, it's kind of --
And it wouldn't have mattered,
because it all changes anyway.
So, yeah, it's sort of you
don't really know
what you're getting into,
and then you get a script
sort of right before
you start shooting and then --
-And it all changes.
-And then it changes every day.
And so --
And then you shoot the movie
and you wrap,
and then it changes again.
-Well, you do that on
"Saturday Night Live," too.
I remember when I was on
that show, they go,
"Don't memorize your scripts."
Because they change
every last minute.
And if you're, like, going like,
"I'm going to get the milk,"
they're like,
"No, we cut that milk bit."
So if you had memorized
that line, that makes no sense.
-It's so nerve-ra--
I mean, for me,
it's just so nerve --
I'm not improvisational.
I'm not -- Yeah.
-Really?
-No.
-You just --
You study your lines
and you go hit your mark
and nail it.
-I'm very controlling.
-Yeah. You are very controlling.
I know you have a
very talented husband, as well,
David E. Kelley.
-Mm-hmm.
-Man, he's on fire again.
-Yeah, he is.
-He kind of never went --
He's always been on fire,
but he's crushing it.
-I know.
-Would you ever work with him?
Would you ever work together?
-No.
-Perfect. Alright, great.
-No, I mean, I --
You know, I'm --
I mean, the way --
Nobody writes, honestly,
better for women than he does.
-He's unbelievable, by the way.
-He's unbelievable.
-He is a talented, talented guy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He really is, yeah.
-And, yet,
I value our relationship
more than a good part,
and I just think it's too risky.
And I think -- And, you know,
we're both kind of fierce
when we work.
And so if I come home and
I've had a bad day
and I'm upset
about something, you know,
I want him to be on my side,
because he hasn't heard
the other side.
-That's really funny.
-You know?
-That's very funny.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, he hasn't heard
the other side.
If he knows
the other side, he'll go,
"Well, wait a second.
It wasn't that bad."
-There's value in that.
-Exactly right.
That's very, very smart.
How did you guys meet?
-It was a blind date.
-Reals?
-Yeah.
-Blind date with
Michelle Pfeiffer?
-I'm not good left
to my own devices, so...
Yeah, my --
-Did he freak out?
I would freak out.
-I think he was --
-If you went to a blind date
and you go,
"Your blind date is
Michelle Pfeiffer" --
-No, I mean, he knew it was me.
It's not blind like that.
-Oh. Not like a reality show?
-No. No. No. Can you imagine?
-Someone set you up -- like
a dinner party or something-ish.
Was it one-on-one?
-Mm...no.
-Ooh!
-I thought it was
a good idea to --
I was kind of nervous, I guess.
And I'd had
a couple of bad blind dates.
And I had sworn off of them,
and my best friend said,
"Please, just this last time,
meet this guy, David Kelley."
I said, "Okay."
So, I thought it was a good idea
to do, like, a bowling party.
-Wow! Really?
-Not a good idea?
-I don't know. Yeah, maybe.
I guess you have to
kind of give it --
I mean,
bowling is very vulnerable.
-Anyway...
-Wearing other people's shoes.
I mean, it's a whole thing.
-So, then we all met
for dinner before...
-I like bowling.
-...which was
the awkward part, probably.
I think the bowling part
was okay.
But then he --
Somehow, he ended up
sitting across from my sister,
and I ended up
sitting across from
his best friend.
And he and my sister were just
chatting it up, you know,
because she's --
you know, she's --
-Charming.
-She's very charming
and really good socially.
I'm not so good.
And he's a little bit shy.
We're both a little bit --
-So you're looking at
your sister like,
"Hey, calm it down
a little bit."
-No, no.
No, I say to my best friend,
"I think I should
set Dedee up with him.
They seem to be
really hitting it off."
She said, "Don't you dare.
I will kill you."
Anyway, she said, "I'm sitting
across from your next husband."
-Your sister said that?
-My best friend said that to me.
-She knew it.
-Wow.
-We hadn't spoken two words.
I don't know how
she thought that,
but that was our --
-But she was right, huh?
-So it didn't start off great.
-Yeah. But how many years
have you been married?
-It'll be 29 this year.
-Yeah, not too shabby.
There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She was right. She was right.
-She was right.
-Every time you come on,
I gush over you backstage.
But I will gush
in front of stage
and just say that you have
so many iconic roles.
You were just in the news
because the new Catwoman,
Zoe Kravitz, was out.
Everyone is
talking about Catwoman,
and everybody's like,
"Michelle Pfeiffer is, like --
I mean, the bar
has been set, you know?"
And I was like,
"Well, yeah --" I go --
I mean,
you were phenomenal in that.
And I checked your Instagram,
and there you are
with the cat -- with the whip.
And you still have the whip.
-I do.
-You took it --
You stole it from the set.
[ Laughter ]
And...
-No.
-You were given it.
-It was my practice whip.
[ Laughter ]
-How would you know
the difference?
Do you know which one
was -- Please.
-No, there's your hero whip...
-Okay. Ooh!
-...and then there's your
practice whip.
-Oh, that's your -- Oh, you got
to keep the practice whip.
-Yeah. So -- Yeah.
-You put in the time.
I mean, you were
actually unbelievable.
-I'm a little rusty,
if you looked at the clip.
-But, yeah -- But, no,
we actually have a clip
from when you were doing
"Batman Returns."
-Mm-hmm.
-Look at this video.
Watch Michelle Pfeiffer.
-Oh, yeah.
How you doing?
Oh! Come on, now!
And you got smoke coming out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What are you doing? Come on.
I want you to have
the hero whip now.
-That was so fun.
-I mean, I want to talk about
"The First Lady" -- okay? --
when we come back, okay?
More with Michelle Pfeiffer,
everybody. Come on back.